all right a lot of wind out there not
enough wind so far says mother nature
we've got more of that to come in fact
that's going to be the biggest element
of the storm but we certainly had a lot
of clouds top wind gusts near 50 miles
an hour up there at kyle canyon the
winds have been over 50 uh higher than
that up there above 8 000 feet overnight
mountain springs summit winds over 30
miles an hour little rough bumpy ride
between parump and las vegas this
morning mccarran a recent wind gust of
30 miles an hour red rock 24 southern
highlands you've had winds near 25 miles
an hour so these winds have actually
pushed the temperatures up a little in
the last half hour so now we've seen
temperatures going up green valley back
up to 70. 67 in henderson 69 now in
downtown mid-60s for aliante to
centennial hills all the way through
summerlin the lakes 63 at mountains edge
and 65 up there on sunrise mountain red
rocket 59 degrees all right so we've got
this atmospheric river i apologize for
the goes satellite picture here keeps
bringing in all of this noise and
disturbance but across the west the
system is breaking apart and spreading
inland so showers and snow showers all
across the intermountain west and it did
push some of that moisture up and over
the sierra nevada range into southern
nevada but it's moving so quickly and
we're so dry we have humidity levels
less than 20 percent so it just doesn't
have time for anything to really gather
and get organized and bring some nice
soaking rains it does look like the
moapa valley may be getting some a
moderate brief shower right now before
it scoots over into northwest arizona so
that's really about the most
organization we've seen out of this
cloud cover since
earlier in the overnight hours mount
charleston 52 degrees had a few snow
flurries up at the ski resort but even
those clouds will give way to sunshine
it'll stay very windy up there upper 70s
with more sun as the day goes on so
afternoon will still be quite warm in
the upper 70s but we'll keep these gusty
winds around out of the south and then
things will calm down overnight we'll
have more sunshine tomorrow and for the
rest of the week and we'll get those
temperatures again right back up near 80
degrees as we head into the weekends
keeping it extra extra mild would have
been nice to get some rain out of the
system nate but it's just moving too
fast